I've decided that, in order to sell more merch, I should do a face reveal wearing some of it. So are you ready?
Here we go!
Boom.
New minimalist and Cold War merch available now
and get the new limited edition Churchill character pin
before it sells out.
With more characters coming in the future
Link in the description down below.
The year is 1917.
Fighting rages on the eastern front of the First World War.
Both Germany and Russia are on the brink of collapse.
- Soldier, I need you to bring me this man.
- Got it.
- Found him, sir.
- Wha-... who ... no...
- Not LennON!
- LenIN! The Russian communist! What! Why would I need a Beatle?! Lenin! The Russian communist! He was exiled to Switzerland!
- You know what? I'll do it myself.
- Who wants to start a revolution?!
*Ussr Anthem starts to play*
OverSimplified: The Cold War
The Germans put Lenin on a train and sent them all the way back to Russia, hoping he and his mates would create an internal crisis.
And create an internal crisis they did.
The government was overthrown and Lenin was in charge.
He immediately pulled out of the First World War, made the country Communist,
started a three-year long civil war, got shot,
broke the economy, caused a famine, and then he died.
On his deathbed, he said,
- "Hey, man, tell whoever's in charge of giving people jobs not to let that jerk Stalin become the next leader.
"By the way, who did I put in charge of giving people jobs?"
- "That would be Stalin, sir."
- (dies)
Stalin was a rising force in the Communist Party.
He still had some opponents but conveniently, all of them were arrested or disappeared.
So that was lucky. And so Stalin took over.
He implemented his five-year plans which transformed the country from an agriculture-based economy
to an industrial one. And like Lenin before him he reigned with terror
Anyone who dared criticize or oppose him would either be killed or left to rot in the horrendous
Soviet war camps. Then a short man with a silly mustache tried to take over the world,
punch the Russians all the way to Moscow, and then the Russians, with some help from their faithful ally, the winter, punched them all the
way back to Berlin. At this point, being allies, America, the UK and the Soviet Union were good chums.
They held a couple of conferences near the end of the war to decide what would happen next
- Hey Stalin, after all your trials and tribulation, you must be pretty happy to be standing here in Berlin.
- Tzar Alexander made it all the way to Paris.
- Uhhh
- Hey, uh, just give me a second.
Hey man, I think something's up with Stalin.
- I know, right? What should we do?
- Shall I tell him about the bomb?
-Yeah, tell him about the bomb. That will scare him.
- Sooo we got this crazy new big A-bomb that can destroy an entire city in one go.
- Yes, my spies told me already.
Oh wait, I meant to act surprised.
WOW! THAT'S AMAZING!
- He already knew! How?!
- Ummm
- Am I sure I want to send nuclear secrets via unsecure, public, coffee-shop Wi-Fi? AM I EVER!
- Dude, use a VPN.
- And speaking of VPNs... If, like me, you take Internet safety seriously
Then you need Nord VPN. Nord VPN hides your online
activities from outside intruders,
preventing anyone from stealing your personal data,
and stopping your service provider selling your data to advertisers,
with over 5,000 servers in 62 countries
It allows you to surf the net anonymously
and securely. And it's simple to use. With just a click of a button, you can connect to a server halfway across the world,
even allowing you to access streaming services from that specific territory
Say, for example,
you wanted to watch a certain OverSimplified video that for some reason has been blocked in your country.
With NordVPN, you can.
It works seamlessly across PC, mobile and tablet.
Go to nordvpn.com/oversimplified
to get an amazing 75% off.
That's just $2.99 per month with an additional month free for limited time.
So again, that's nordvpn.com/oversimplified, also in the description box down below.
Now, where were we?
Oh, yeah.
Does the 'A' stand for atomic or ass?
Then America dropped their big 'A' bomb on Japan and WWII officially came to an end.
- Hooray! We won!
Okay, so now it's time to establish the New World Order.
Stalin, you're in charge of Eastern Europe.
Now, we want you to let them all hold elections.
- Oh, yes, of course. Elections.
- And these elections will be free and fair, right?
- Certainly. Free and fair. Definitely free and fair.
Communist, Communist, Communist, Communist, Communist, Communist.
If that's not free and fair, I don't know what is.
Throughout Eastern Europe, Soviet puppet governments were established as a buffer zone between the
USSR and the West, with Churchill proclaiming an Iron Curtain had descended across the continent.
The relationship between the old allies was deteriorating fast.
Over the next few years the British intervened in the Greek Civil War
to prevent a communist takeover.
In Turkey the Russians began demanding more control of Turkey's c-axis rats, which prompted the U.S.
to send their largest battleship to Turkey for a friendly visit after World War two Iran was now occupied by both the Soviets and the
British with an agreement to both pull out
Once the war was over the British pulled out Stalin was like you know what?
I think I might stick around.
All in favor of kicking Russia out of Iran?
You want to know something
You guys suck. Pressure from the UN forced the Soviets to leave
and with the establishment of NATO, the Soviets had no doubt that the West was out to encircle and destroy them.
And America announced the Truman Doctrine.
In which they basically said "Those guys are not cool, cannot be trusted
And we will do everything we can to prevent the spread of Communism around the world"
Many view this moment as the official declaration of the Cold War.
Back in Europe...
Everyone was living in a post-apocalyptic void brought on by the Second World War.
Cities reduced to rubble, not enough food
It was terrible. This is great the more they suffer the more likely it is they'll turn to communism!
Dude, you're really messed up. Whats wrong with you?
My father used to punish me severely.
America realized what was going on, and quickly made a move.
Under the Marshall Plan; They sent 12 billion dollars to Western Europe for its economic recovery.
The countries of Stalin's Eastern Bloc looked on with envy.
- Hey Czechoslovakia. You want to come get some economic aid?
- Yeah, but I have to check with my mom first
- Sorry America...
- I can't come
This was a full-on economic battle raging between capitalism and communism in Europe.
If the Western nations developed faster and better than the East, that would be a defeat for Stalin.
So he set up his own rival economic recovery plan
Which he called comic-con, and he also set up Cominform which gave him more political control over the Eastern Bloc
But nowhere did this economic battle rage harder than in the city of Berlin.
Got over a hundred miles behind Soviet lines
The city had been divided up between the Allies
and the western segments were still under Western control.
East Berliners could travel freely to West Berlin, see the economic prosperity and think
"Hmmm...
Maybe this communism thing ain't so great after all.
I'm gonna have fun tonight!"
- You're home late.
- oh
- Stalin I was just out with my friends.
- Friends?!
You stink of capitalism! You're out engaging an imperialist debauchery again
I swear Ivan, I can't keep doing this
Stalin wanted the West out.
So he said "Hey, guess what?
I'm blockading all of your supply routes to West Berlin. What are you gonna do about it?"
"I suppose we'll just fly the supplies in."
"Alright Truman, you win this round"
The Berlin Airlift was an incredible undertaking and a major success for the Western Allies.
And Stalin ended his blockade of West Berlin.
His aggressive actions worried the West, but not as much as this did
*A-Bomb Exploddd*
The Soviet Union had developed their very own atomic bomb.
The USA no longer had a nuclear monopoly.
The world now knew that if a major war broke out between the two superpowers
It would be more destructive than anyone could imagine.
So it was comforting when Stalin came out and said that war between the Soviet Union and the West was unlikely. Oh wait inevitable
He said it was inevitable. Hey, you know who I haven't checked in on in a while my good friend, China
Whoa, what happened to you? What happened to them was a full-blown civil war that had been going on since 1927?
The People's Liberation Army under the leadership of Mao Zedong
Successfully defeated the Republic of China who fled to Taiwan that now communist China and the Soviet Union signed a mutual defense treaty
This was terrible news for the West but wait. There's more after the Second World War
Korea was divided along the 38th parallel in the north the Soviets set up a communist regime in the south
America set up an anti communist regime both were led by very sweet looking old men
But don't let that deceive you they were both
Ruthless dictators and both dreamed of reuniting Korea under their own regime now that he had the bomb Stalin was feeling a little more cocky
And he finally gave Kim permission to attack the North launched a surprise invasion of the south on June 25th
1950 with Soviet aid the North Koreans steamrolled through taking Seoul in just three days and replacing one ruthless dictator with another
The UN were freaking out and quickly created an emergency force made up of troops from 16 countries to defend the south the West still
Held to son and made landings at Incheon near Seoul
they pushed the North Koreans out of Seoul replacing the ruthless dictator that I replaced the first realistic hitter with the same ruthless dictator that
are previously been replaced by the new ruthless dictator and the
West then continued all the way up the Korean Peninsula at this point China was getting worried that the UN may just keep going the
U.s. Had sent this guy to lead the operation after winning the Pacific theater of World War two General Douglas
MacArthur's head was big and his balls were bigger
He reassured President Truman that there was absolutely no way at all that the Chinese would ever get involved
Meanwhile half a million Chinese troops were crossing into Korea Neukom. No Newcomb. No
Oh, come on, you're fired the u.s. Considered the nuclear option
But now that the Soviets also had the bomb they didn't want to risk all-out global destruction
The Communists pushed the West right back almost to the exact same spot
They it all started from and they ended up in a stalemate where they remained until both sides
Finally agreed to work towards the peace settlement in 2018 back in America
Americans decided they wanted a new president who would be tough on communism
So they elected famed World War two General Eisenhower who is really hard to draw
it's
1953 hey stone, how you doing? Oh, he's dead
He had a cerebral hemorrhage and his reign of terror
Kinda came back to bite him in the ass because he had imprisoned all of his best doctors and those that were left were too
Terrified to treat him the new leader Nikita Khrushchev called a meeting and said hey guys
You know how Stalin was imprisoning and murdering herself for doing basically nothing. Yeah. He was kind of a jerk
I'm really not sure how this is news to you. Khrushchev went on a campaign of desalinization
statues of stone were taken down
Stalingrad was renamed and Khrushchev announced that he wanted the Soviet people to be happy and would allow greater freedom in the Soviet Union
So how did that work out?
Well an uprising in East Germany was brutally suppressed a revolution in Hungary was brutally suppressed and demonstrations in Poland were brutally suppressed
Although he did finally allow some mild reforms back in the Soviet Union
He permitted more cultural expression, but then began banning stuff based on his own personal tastes modern art
looks like a child urinated on canvas band jazz music sounds like the feeling of needing to fart and
Your poetry is really depressing
How could anyone in the Soviet Union be depressed your band?
Khrushchev wanted the Soviet people to be happy but not like that or that or that
Young people began enjoying a boring Western pop culture Sun remove that disgusting imperialist apparel at once. Shut up dad
You can't tell me what to do
What would you look at that turns out he can tell me what to do
The West had initially liked the cut of Khrushchev's jib
But world events soon soured relations
Even more the two sides were spying on each other a whole lot throughout the Cold War the KGB had spies and informants in nearly
Every aspect of Western life and government so much so that whenever the u.s
Tried to send spies into the Soviet Union the KGB were usually ready to arrest them on this spot members of the Manhattan Project
Aided the Soviet Union in acquiring the bomb some American officials believe they on the wrong side
I'll sell you three secrets for five million dollars. Okay, go ahead
The Allies are digging a tunnel under East Berlin to tap your communications
There's an American agent living at this address in Moscow and sometimes when I'm home alone
I like to put on my wife's dresses sit in the corner and cry for hours
Very interesting in America fear took hold during the Red Scare and the McCarthy trials American values imploded as fear of communism
Collided with freedom of thought and expression and communist kind of became a buzzword thrown around to describe anything people didn't like Hollywood
communists your next-door neighbor's dog
communist when the grocery store cashier asks
If you need a bag when you clearly can't carry ten tons of bacon aids in your hands communists
But one area in particular where the US had an edge over the Soviet Union was in its espionage technology in particular
You to spy planes flew across Russia carrying out surveillance from the skies
There was a nasty incident in 1961 when while we shut down and Khrushchev was furious who the hell is this?
He's up. Very naughty high-altitude weather enthusiasts (lol)
why does he have a gun in a poison needle because
But much to America's concern the Soviet Union appeared to be ahead in the space race
Everyone freaked out when Russia launched the world's first satellite
And then they actually sent a man into space
Even worse there also appeared to be a missile gap in the Soviets favor and Khrushchev was so confident that even allowed the u.s
To set up a technology exhibit in Moscow attended by a certain Vice President Richard Nixon. Check this out. We have color TV
Yes, but we've been to space and can obliterate you with our massive nuclear arsenal
Check out this vegetable peeler tensions increased further when both sides upgraded their atomic bombs to hydrogen bombs
And after West Germany was allowed to join NATO in 1955 Khrushchev set up the defense of Warsaw Pact
Strengthening the military ties between the Soviet Union and it's satellites States in
1960 Americans decided they wanted a new president who would be tough on communism
So they elected John F Kennedy the Soviet Union was advancing its technology
But it was also bleeding its coffers dry and all of the money was going towards the military
Not the people life under communism was still as hard as ever and Berlin
Remained a thorn in the Soviet side the contrast between the economically prosperous West and the struggling East was clearer day-by-day and East Berliners were
Still able to freely travel to the West now many of them were deciding to stay there
Millions defected to West Germany via West Berlin causing Eastern factories to lose workers and taking a heavy toll on the economy
Soviet leaders decided this couldn't continue any longer first Khrushchev tried this leave West Berlin or else or else what or else?
I'll be really mad at you. Yeah, no, we're gonna stay. Listen man. West Berlin is ours East Berlin is yours
That's just how it is. Kennedy felt pretty good about a show of American resolve. But wait a second. Did you catch that?
Let's reply it. Uh
Kennedy just told cruise shop that the USA wouldn't interfere in what the Soviets did with their section of Berlin
So Khrushchev came up with a new idea
We're gonna build a wall and it's gonna be a big beautiful wall and it's gonna keep out all the Mexicans
*Whisper* No, Sir that's wrong its going to keep in the east Berliner's.
Oh, sorry. It's gonna keep in all the Mexicans on
August 13th
1961 Berliners woke up to find their city divided into two with barbed wire and guards blocking the border between East and West
Over time a wall was constructed throughout the city families were torn apart
Thousands would risk their lives
Escaping over the wall and hundreds would die trying to the despair of Berliners the West were unable to do anything about it
But the wall did put on full display the failure of the communist system as Kennedy said democracy is not perfect
but we have never had to put a wall up to keep our people in as
Part of the agreement between the two sides US diplomats were still allowed to travel to East Berlin
But suddenly East Berlin crossing guard started givin them the business and Kennedy was like nah
in October the US rolled tanks up to the crossing point at Checkpoint Charlie as a show of strength the Soviets did the same and
The two were in a standoff, they stayed like that for sixteen hours and the world braced for nuclear Armageddon
Thankfully them Kennedy called Khrushchev directly and was like, hey man, this is getting way too hot
How about you back your tanks up by an inch and we'll do the same. Sounds good. Okay
How about you back your tanks up by another inch and we'll follow suit. All right
*Drink tea*
*Wall been smashed*